if you're a business owner or work for
one this presentation may be the most
tactical thing that I can do to make you
money I think this one's going to be a
really big hitter which is why I wanted
to do it live to you guys um so let me
ask you guys a question who believes
that you have to work hard to make money
real question
okay who believes that no one can
outwork them okay good I have at least
some honest people in this room um well
I'm going to attempt to prove some of
you wrong who believe that you can never
be out work because I see that on the
internet all the time and it drives me
banana
um and the reason this is so important
defining work is that all of us claim to
work every day and yet most of us can't
even Define the word and so how do you
define work so we can use the science
definition which is you know work equals
force time distance problem is that
that's not very useful for knowledge
workers for what we do uh do we use the
time on clock definition you know time
spent working as our inputs prob is you
know work 16 18 hours a day and so if
everyone is already doing that then how
can one person work harder than another
okay okay um so then do we Define it by
how hard you try so the effort that you
expend is the work that you do well do
you want participation trophies and
people just saying like yes you tried
your hardest is this how you want your
employees to gauge themselves well I
tried really hard even though I suck
it's like well okay and so if it's if
work isn't four times distance if it's
not just the time you put in and if it's
not just how hard you try then what is
work and so we better be clear on what
it is we're trying to to do to make
money right if we're going to do more of
it to make more money and so this is my
definition which is work equals
outputs and outputs equal volume times
leverage so some of you guys have seen
this for me before and the Plaine is the
number of times you do something times
how much you get out of each time you do
it fundamentally that's what it is and
so the next question that follows is
well then how do we work faster or how
do we do more work per unit of time and
so that's volume times leverage divided
by time and so the plain speak is output
per unit okay and so if you want to the
most per unit of time please pay
attention because I do think that this
will help you and so how can we get more
out of the time we put in which in the
game of business is money and so now
everyone's like attention you know perks
up they're like ah that that stuff I
would like that and so visual for you so
volume is the number of times you do the
thing leverages how much you get out of
each time you do it equals your output
how many times you do it times how much
time you get equals your output and so
some quick examples and you guys can
tell me whether it's high or low all
right is this high output or low
output this is low it's very hard to do
that with very low leverage high or low
high great high or low higher
exactly high or
low highest because we have a lot of
volume on good leverage and so now we
understand what work is you can either
do more activity do more stuff or get
more for it to get get higher output and
so normally I spend the vast majority of
my career talking about leverage but
today I actually want to talk about
volume and the reason for that is
because talking to a lot of businesses
and um I have taken for granted that
people do all the volume stuff and it
turns out after talking to many of you
that is just not true and so here I am
talking about leverage because I just
assume you work your ass off um and
that's fundamentally false for most of
you um and I'm baffled by how little
people people actually work when they
think they are working it's for
you and so I'm going to cover two things
today number one clear on the input that
grows your business the most two is
removing everything that isn't that from
your
life my disclaimer is that this is for
business owners and specifically your
highest level employees and so if you're
like taking notes and you're like hey I
want to send this to my team I would
recommend because my team saw these
slides beforehand and I had like two
guys being like I'm going to change a
whole bunch of stuff and I was like
great and that's my sign for good
presentation so figuring out the right
input let's say that you want to grow
your business you can either get more
customers or you can make them worth
more that's it you either sell more
units increase LTV done so breaking this
into actions for customers you either
get more traffic or you convert a higher
percentage of them of the traffic you
have that's the action making them worth
more you raise prices decrease your cost
of goods sold buy more get people to buy
more stuff more times those are the
things that's all you got and if you
look at four things what do you actually
do well to get more traffic you have to
advertise more better to increase your
conversion you have to practice sales or
you have to improve your offer if you
want to raise your prices you just have
to grow goads and decide by the way
goads are are both both sexes so there
you go there's my PC for the day buy
more times which would be decreasing
turn you have reach outs you have exit
interviews you do pre- payments you
improve your on boarding you get faster
results you hold events to appreciate
members or clients
but if you look at your time you do
almost none of these
things you're not doing this stuff now
and that's why you're probably not
making money or as much as you want and
so if you don't do this stuff all the
time that you spend quote working has
the same impact as doing
nothing and it's kind of like spending
your entire week thinking about how
you're going to build and redesign your
website and then deciding not to do it
except it's just more tiresome than just
watching Netflix and relaxing and so
you'd literally be better off doing
nothing than doing the work that you
claim to be work that actually
isn't and so that's why most of the
businesses here are stuck and why many
people watching this at home aren't
growing as fast as they
want and so for most of you especially
the smaller businesses your effort
should be disproportionately here on
getting more traffic advertising more
advertising better and higher con
conversion meaning your actual
activities on a daily basis is letting
more people know about your stuff and
practicing getting them to give you
money when they find out about it that
is what you do on a regular basis with a
vast majority of your time after all if
you do not have customers then there is
no one that you can raise his prices on
and that you can get to buy more times
and increase their lifetime value and so
let's pick apart this first one first
advertising more and better so you
advertise better by advertising more
Excellence comes from repetition when we
even use volume as a measure for skill
like I've taken 4,000 sales consults we
even say that we use it as a proxy and
yet we don't think about that for our
own skill and business and so if you
want to get unreasonably good at
advertising do so much advertising that
it would be unreasonable for you to suck
after doing that much of it again we're
just defining inputs here so if you run
ads it means you commit to spending four
hours a day scripting analyzing writing
copying recording ads which may mean
learning how to use editing software or
an
iPhone if you use Outreach it means
spending four hours a day reaching out
to people across social media platforms
if you use content as your primary
advertising then you make content for
four hours a day every day and you make
it on every
platform if you use partners and
Affiliates it means spending four hours
a day doing Outreach ads or making
content to help your Affiliates send you
more
customers so these actions become the
volume that create the
outputs which for many of you is more
leads and if you're hearing 4 hours a
day and thinking how will I have time to
do everything else remember that doing
everything else is
what's this is what your time looks like
when your business is
stalled this is what your time looks
like when your business is
growing and so too many of you if you're
honest with yourself your days look like
this and expect results that look like
this I told you I'll just give you a
really thorough
answer and so before you say but I need
to keep doing insert whatever thing that
isn't growing your business remember you
guys can do whatever you want but if you
keep doing the same stuff and your
business isn't growing then the stuff
that you're doing is wrong it is not the
right stuff and you have to learn how to
let some fires
burn some problems are problems but they
not the problem of the business
today and this is the essence of
strategy you learn to prioritize some
things are more important than others
which means yes you can neglect them for
a
season then when they actually become
the true limiter of the business the
true constraint then you focus on them
four hours a day until you solve it and
so if you use these four things as our
guide let's say you master traffic and
you're getting loads of leads but you
can't close a barn door if the wind was
behind you right then conversion becomes
your limiter and so then you train
someone else on the advertising stuff
you do because you mastered it and then
spend four hours a day trying to
optimize your
conversion which might look like this
you might actually track your close rate
for a change you might actually report
all your sales interactions and do them
from behind the person you actually see
their identity this is for Brick and mor
people and have a sign on your door that
says that you record so you can do this
legally watch game tape of sales that
actually worked every single morning you
practice your script out loud every
single day you hire someone who can give
you feedback ideally daily on how well
you sell you have a two-minute mental
prep before you take consults every
single time you give a pre-sale
questionnaire to every person who walks
in the door if you're bricking Mort or
you have some sort of thing online to
get them ready for the sale you qualify
people on the phone better to pre-sell
them and then you actually do that every
time there we go you guys getting this
cool okay so all problems are solvable
with skills and all skills are
attainable repetition and feedback and
once you have a skill you can do it in
less time which gives you Leverage so
you get more for what you do the better
you get at it the less time it takes for
you to do it so you get more time
back in other words once you get great
at sales you don't need to switch As
Much Time on it and you'll still close
the same percentage you go from growing
a skill to maintaining a skill and it's
much easier to maintain a skill and
continue to stay at that same level than
it is to gain a skill and so it's kind
of like maintaining weight if you've
ever like lost weight or gained weight
like once you get to that level it's
much easier to stay and maintain that it
is to to break the whatever the word is
homeostasis and same thing for gaining
muscle and everything you spend your
time on has to clearly lad up to one of
these four things and so right now if
you look at your schedule and you're not
lading up to these four things you're
not doing the stuff that makes
money otherwise you're just doing this
rather than this but still some of you
guys are going to be thinking to
yourselves well with what time out I can
barely keep water as is I'm very busy
understandable and if you have a special
snowflake excuse I'm special um you're
totally right it's literally impossible
for you to do what I'm saying and that's
why your business will never grow cool
and that is my talk for today
now be better of course you're rights
will never grow right happy now you're
totally justifies not achieving your
goals consider yourself excused all
right so for everyone else right
um we just have to face reality success
the marketplace your customers they
don't care about whatever your excuse is
and it may be entirely Justified it also
doesn't matter and they also don't
care they just care about output they
care about what they can get from you
what's in it for me and so if you're
open to the idea that might a little bit
about making money and growing
businesses I want to get to the second
part of my presentation which was that
was my 11-e transformation that's my
before and
after how to make this easier for you so
I said I was going to cover two things
the first is how to get very clear on
the inputs that grow your business every
feel very clear on the four things that
you need to do and how they lad up to
activities that you spend four hours a
day
and you're like great but I don't have
four hours a day well that's why we're
going to do the second part which is
removing everything else that isn't that
from your life and so the nice part
about this second half of the
presentation is that there's nothing to
argue about it's just facts we all have
24 hours a day I'm good there so far
I've just stated facts okay people who
move faster just do better things with
their
time you can cut grass with scissors and
it will take all day or you can make one
call and have someone else do it in
either scenario both people get the
grass
cut and so we outlined that you need to
spend your time working on those four
levers in your business at least four
hours a day and so I'm going to show you
how to find the time with a combination
of habits and buying time this may be
one of the more tactical things that I
give you guys that will probably change
your life from this whole experience so
first we have to find time and second we
will buy time so let's start with
finding time so there's two types of
work that every entrepreneur has you've
got maker time you've got manager time
maker time is long blocks of
uninterrupted time four to six hours you
only have 14 work blocks per week of
this maker time it's very very valuable
it's low urgency High importance work
that's the stuff that moves the business
forward a productive maker calendar is
an empty calendar an interruption always
destroys an entire time block who here
has had a Time block where you're like
really excited and then a 1-hour call
comes in at 10: a.m. and you're like
well there goes my morning yes we've all
been there and you hate that person and
this is what maker time looks
like looks great look at that beautiful
blue space so much work so much money to
be made
made on the other hand you've got
manager time and we manage both of these
things these are time blocks as small as
5 to 15 minutes you've 100 of these plus
per week the goal is to fill your
calendar with these slots if you're in
your manager time and you're are Maxim
manager when you have no gaps and this
is usually when you're spending time
training teams coordinating
communicating putting out fires and this
is what it looks like when you're on
manager time this is also my calendar
when I'm on a manager day and both of
these work styles are important everyone
here has worn both of these hats right
okay but the moment these two hats meets
is when disaster happens and so if
you're trying to in tiny slices of
management into your making time kill
half a day it doesn't
work and if you have lots of empty slots
between your managing time it's also
inefficient there too because you're not
doing anything with that time you might
as well fill it with more meetings and
so you have to understand what type of
work you're doing when you start the day
and explain to your team the difference
between these types of work and the
importance of those time periods and why
you have to prioritize them the entire
business can grow and so beyond
explaining the difference in the of work
I don't know why I keep going out there
um here's what I did to facilitate maker
time because manager time kind of always
happens so here are the maker habits
that I have so one is I decide the one
project I need to work on that's most
important and yes it can be the same
thing for a while I woke up at 4:00 a. I
worked until 9:00 a.m. on that work 5
hours that's how I work I turned off all
my notifications I have a dark room my
office now still has no windows um no
sound earplugs I keep it very very
simple I want to put everything out of
my world besides the work and I realize
that there are no emergencies so this is
something that for all entrepreneurs we
have to understand is that there are no
emergencies there's 911 someone's dying
in which case call them not me and then
there's the emergency that your business
isn't going to grow for the third year
in a row which you need to solve
now which also means going to bed at the
same time every single night is a habit
that served me very well and that also
includes weekend I just and if you're
like how do I do that I always go to
sleep late just wake up early once and
be tired that's how it
works it's my brilliant idea treat
weekends and weekdays the same and
realize that drinking cost you two days
the day you drink and the day you
recover and some makers work late at
night after their kids have gone to
sleep anyone here who have that is that
your time slot for making okay cool it
doesn't matter what your time slot is as
long as you make time for it just find
the four to five hours that you can turn
everything off and working weekends is
also a hack that you can move forward
it's 104 days a year the amount of
entrepreneurs that're like I take
weekends off like 104 days of
uninterrupted time okay got it
understood well I'd love to compete
against you anyways so those are some of
the habits that help me find time to do
the things that matter most the second
is buying time so let's talk about that
so you are the most valuable person in
your business you produce the most most
value for the company and if you had a
star employee You' want to maximize
their ever weeking moment right if
you've got everybody here have some
person you're like man I just want to
clear the way for them I just want them
to just keep working working working
okay and we often do this with our teams
right we try and Empower them we try and
clear their calendars trying to give
them help but we don't do this for
ourselves and so there's the myth of
work life and personal life you know
integration or whatever and this isn't
that talk believe me I don't care about
that talk what I mean is that we all
have one battery and the problem with
your spouse and your kids and your
chores and your employees is they all
drain from the same source and so you
become more productive by eliminating
the things that make you unproductive
more than you have some pomodora time
hack and like this is what I really want
to have syn in you will become more
productive through elimination than by
adding
optimization just by taking away all the
things that are not the things that grow
the
business and so I also bring this up
because no one ever sticks with that
stuff anyways we all see the Tik Tock
hack of like put a timer and then take a
walk or like no one does it no one does
it no one doesn't so let's let's just
forget about it why
bother but cutting things out they are
permanent reductions and energy drainage
that you can reallocate to making more
money doing the stuff that matters and
so if we all have 24 hours a day someone
who works on the most important stuff
for 16 hours six days a week is going to
move way faster than someone who's who
does it three hours per week in real
real work time some of you guys if you
look back on your last week you're like
how much real maker time did I make for
myself to work on the stuff that grows
the business many times if you're really
honest with yourself it's like four
hours and so there's a reason that
someone could actually move 30 times
faster than
you and that's the
difference if you're doing three hours
of productive or 96 productive hours
it's just the math and so it's not even
close that's how you move 30 times
faster than somebody else even though
both people work all
day and so hopefully they convince you
about how important this is and maybe
why other people you know move faster
than
you and so let's get really tactical the
average American spends 50 hours per
month on food groceries eating prepping
cleaning the replacement cost for that
is $800 a
month the average American spends 25
hours per month cleaning their home the
replac cost for that is $500 a month the
average American spend 16 hours per
month doing laundry washing drying
folding organizing dry cleaning driving
to laundromat $200 a month to replace
that which means that for $1,500 a month
you can get 96 hours per month back
that's two full work weeks every single
month and that means that if you can
make more than $15 per hour with your
time you should make that trade seven
days a week twice on Sunday and once for
your
mom and this is very much a form of
reinvesting in
yourself but you have to use the time
that you buy to work to make even more
so this isn't the I will spend $1,500 a
month and then I will get 96 hours back
and I will watch 96 more hours of
Netflix this is not that plan and I
bring this up amazed at how many
people feel like they're being
irresponsible by spending this money
like the amount of entrepreneurs that I
talk to that are like that will happily
hire somebody for $50,000 a year and are
unwilling to think about the idea of
spending $1500 a month on things that
make them feel fancy or frilly or like
exess expenses is
ridiculous I'll say that is silly but if
you could spend $1,500 a month on your
most valuable employee forget about you
for a second you're most valuable
employee to have 50% more out of them
wouldn't you do that every day of the
week and twice on Sunday of course but
you are that more valuable employee you
are that person in the business by far
not even close it's you
and I didn't even get into into the free
40 hours a week that people spend all
right so following sports teams four
hours a week replacement cost of not
following sports teams zero dollar
watching TV 21 hours a week on average
replacement M literally nothing
scrolling social media 17 hours a week
also literally nothing driving to and
from work and refilling gas four and a
half hours a week replacement cost is
$700 a month for Uber you have somebody
else drive you I tweet on my way to work
and I tweet on my way back where I get
my content
and for $1,500 a month you can still do
those fun things so I'm not even I'm not
even taking those out because you're not
going to do it anyways you're still
going to watch TV you're still going to
you're still GNA scroll social media
you're gonna do all that stuff not even
gonna try you can still that stuff and
spend $1,500 a month and get 96 hours a
month
back and so I want to be clear this is a
one-time investment you will never get
this back I can't resend the $1,500 and
get another 96 hours back you only get
to pull this trigger once and I'm still
amazed at the businesses that are doing
50 100 $500,000 a month and they still
are analyzing this bill as something
that they have even hesitated to spend
money on because of whatever narrative
they have around why it's good to clean
your own
laundry or cook your own food now sure
if you like cooking and it's
recreational then fine but you and I
both know that's not what we're talking
about it's lunch on Tuesday that's what
I'm talking
about and so there are so few things
that you can spend $1,500 a month on
getting 96 hours per month
back and you can only pull the trigger
once and so this advice is so simple and
yet when I see rooms like this with the
same problems again and again and again
I had to make this incredibly obvious
presentation because the only thing
that's easier than doing this is not
doing it which is what most of you will
probably do is you will nod and you will
think about it and then you will do
nothing and you will still cook your
[__] food and you will still drive
yourself to work and you will still
still clean your house you're like well
I like my clothes folded a certain way
who
cares like is it worth the business not
growing by 50% this
year and somehow those of you who do
nothing will be amazed while you're
later you're still in the exact same
position while someone else who took
these simple steps 30X their
output and this is how you can actually
do your day job as the manager while
also giving yourself the time to do what
matters most as a maker those 96 hours
you can take those four hours a day and
it's there that's just from the stats
that's not just me like that's it's
right there you can have
it and so this trading up for time is
buying time and it
it it's less valuable work that you
trade money for for more free time to do
more valuable work that you then trade
to get more money and you just never
stop this NE this whole process never
ends and so bringing this all
together that's the stuff that actually
grows your business if you work on the
right stuff your business will grow like
getting more customers making them worth
more and if you want to do as much and
you want to do as much of that as you
can to grow your business as fast as you
can and make sure your day looks like
this not like that and to do that in the
real
world you eliminate everything else
that's not that which you do by
understanding and explaining the differ
between maker and manager yourself and
your teams and giving yourself time
every single day to decide the project
that matters most wake up a little bit
earlier turn off your notifications get
a zone that you can actually
work investing your most valuable
employee by eliminating 96 hours per
month of work for $1,500 a
month so that you can actually work not
to 2X or Forex more effective let me say
that again so you can work not just two
or four times more effective than your
competition but 30 times more effective
than them because they're like you super
distracted have their notifications
turned on are taking calls in the middle
of the day and they too are only working
three hours or productive hours a week
and you can absolutely murder them in
their sleep by how much you crush them
in business if you actually spend the
time to do the things that matter which
almost no one does and it's crazy
because I spend all this time making all
this business content about LTV to C
ratios and decrease inur and make sure
your onboarding is on board is
streamlined people are like I don't have
the time find the [__] time buy it
it's right there it's for
sale and so you maximize your time and
actually work on the things that matter
which everyone else would then wonder
when you actually do this how does he
move so fast how does she move so fast
but you will know the secret is that
there is no secret you have one battery
and you just try and eliminate as many
drains as you can that aren't aligned
with your
goal and that's how you can compress
multiple lifetimes of growth into one
thank
you any questions on this is this uh was
there was there anything that was
unclear about that presentation go for
it what time do you go to sleep uh so I
get in bed at 9: I go to sleep by 10:
you get up 4 uh I'm probably up well
today I was up at four but like most of
the times I'm up by like five yeah 10 to
fives works fine I like I've haven't had
an alarm in like five seven years I a
long time um I'm a big fan so I probably
should add this is that I think you
should have a sleep alarm not a wake up
alarm I mean I sleep as long as you can
because like if I don't know about you
but like if I get nine hours of sleep
I'm like I can cure cancer today like
like I I so rarely get nine like if I
get seven you know I'm I'm fine but nine
like I I literally look at Lea I'm like
give me the hardest problems today like
like I'll just sit in in discomfort go
for it manag time
sure yeah so I think okay so the
question was um is it okay to make your
goal eliminating manager time um I see
it as a Continuum rather than an
absolute or a binary so it's not like I
am 100% maker or I'm 100% manager I
think it's just how much of that so like
Leela's calendar is flipped from mine so
I have four days a week of maker time
and one manager day on Mondays which I
just stack the living hell out of I'm
just like just I just tell the team I
was like just destroy me just just put
everything in there I expect to
accomplish nothing and I will just make
all the decisions and talk to everybody
about all the
stuff the other four days I work on
things that I think matter most and I
also work the
weekends her schedule is more like this
where she has four days a week where she
has their manager time in one day a week
that's maker time she also spends the
weeker do week ends doing maker stuff
and so that's kind of how she balances
it um because Lea actually runs
everything in the business I take credit
for running everything in the business
that's kind of our division uh it's
worked well for us for years yeah so
recommend yeah shoot how much time you
spend
on I just tweeted about this like 10
minutes ago which is great yeah so how
much time do I spend on Fitness stuff in
general so my big advice is get in shape
between 18 and 24 and then after that
the maintenance of being in shape it
takes like 10% of your time which I was
alluding to in the presentation and so
it takes me very little time to maintain
this um but I now have a gym downstairs
and so it's super super easy uh but you
know I work out when I can I usually
probably work out three four days a week
and it's just downstairs and I do it in
the morning or I do in the
afternoon keep the relationship not turn
off make it more of a business relation
so how do we I'm repeating it because no
one has a mic just so you know um so how
do we manag being married and being
co-managers of the business always
talking about the business
oh so we always talk about
business I think what we don't do is
Judge ourselves for talking about
business I think more people get
stressed about what they think they
should be doing rather than just being
like this is our relationship these are
our rules which we make and we don't
think they exist it's worked fine so far
if one of us wasn't into business it
would
suck it's all I want to talk
about
shoot this is this is [__] awesome so
the question was do I have uh do I have
fun outside of of work um the majority
of my fun is in work uh
but I take like one or two vacations a
year that are like three or four days um
and we try to do it with friends of ours
because most of the friends that we have
don't live where we live and so most the
friends that we have not most all the
friends that we have are all pretty high
level entrepreneurs and they're really
busy too and so we try and have you know
company there while we can all talk
about business and talk about you know
what we're excited about and that's what
works for us you know there the first I
think three years of our marriage we
didn't take any I mean we didn't take we
didn't do a honeymoon we work the day we
got married we work the next day um
we're like we but we do us though and so
I don't like I don't for every like I
don't see this as prescription we just
do we just do what we want to do um and
so I always hesitate with those those
questions because people take it as
gospel and I just like we really really
spend a long time trying to not care
about what anyone else thinks about what
we
do
okay
yeah so how often do I review what the
constraint is in the
business your business constraint
doesn't change that often once you get
it right and so once you know it's like
okay I need to advertise more you just
keep doing that until you break
something else and sometimes you can do
that for a very very very very very long
time and the constraint then goes one is
chunked down so it's like we need to
okay so it's like you're advertising and
you're running ads but you're like I
need a second channel so you're still
like the the bigger constraint is still
the same I need more leads but you need
to have the constraint of like I need to
solve this next acquisition Channel and
so it'll it'll move against the larger
constraint of the business but finally
all the constraints are going to chunk
up to I need to get more customers I
need make them worth more and I might
need to make them more so that I can get
more customers and so those will
oscillate back and forth um on the
business the big thing that will matter
is kind of benchmarks is understanding
like I think we were talking earlier
when the guys were there with the med
spa um he had a LTV issue he didn't have
a leads issue and so it's making sure
that we're solving the right problem and
I see a lot of business owners really
obsessing trying to drive down lead
costs and I find it to be more easy to
just fix the sales process and add a
zero to your price and then all of a
sudden all your lead problems go away
and so it's it's I try and find the
easiest way to solve problems which
often times
isn't the thing that's immediately
apparent so I'll tell you I'll tell you
a fun a fun so we have so the book
launch is g to come up at some point um
and so I was thinking about some of the
goodies that I was going to be giving
away and one of the goodies I had was
like like legit like 400 more hours of
work and so I started the project and I
stopped after an hour and I was like
okay can I use my second brain cell here
and think of something else that I can
give away that's more valuable than this
that doesn't take me 400 hours and it
took me like an hour to think of
something else that was better and took
less time and so I think sometimes like
the the pendulum swing on the other side
of this is if you have tremendous work
ethic then sometimes you want to solve
problems the hard way but there's like
this is something that I feel like I've
found more and more as I've like gotten
doggy years aged in business is like
like there's usually a more elegant
solution if you just take a second and
you're like and I like asking
hypotheticals of like what would it take
two or if I had to make something more
valuable in a tenth of the time what
would I do if someone 10 times smarter
than me had the same problem what would
they do and like cycling through those
frames helped me attack the problem
differently and that that helps me a lot
like I use those frames a lot when I'm
trying to solve things guys I appreciate
you all hope you enjoyed the uh the
Youtube video thank you much appreciate
you